Russian President Vladimir Putin's
calling up reservists to fight in the
war in Ukraine he made the announcement
during a rare address in the nation the
defense minister says the partial
mobilization will involve drafting about
300 000 Personnel the decision comes as
Russian troops lose ground to Ukraine's
counter-offensive in the Northeast
meanwhile Moscow backed separatists in
four Ukrainian regions have said they'll
hold a referendum to become part of
Russia
it is necessary to support the proposal
of the ministry of defense and the
general staff to hold a partial military
mobilization in Russia I repeat we are
talking of a partial mobilization only
only people in the military Reserve will
be drafted the priority will be on
people who served in the armed forces
have military specialization and
experience those drafted before being
sent to the places of service will have
mandatory additional training relying on
experience gained during the special
military operation the decree on partial
mobilization has been signed
Alexander is joining us live from keeps
we're getting some more information
about what this partial mobilization is
going to be about but it's going to take
time to put all of this into place isn't
it
yeah it sure is because these are
reservists that are being called and
they're being called to uh being called
up it goes into effect immediately uh
Russia is saying that they're going to
go through retraining at military bases
before being sent out onto the front
lines or at least onto the Ukrainian
battlefield but some analysts are saying
that this is going to be tough for
Russia because these aren't necessarily
the best fighters the best fighters were
the ones that potentially were already
on the front lines of the war here and
so that this is going to take time for
Russia to get some of these reservists
retrained get them to bases and then to
deploy them out into the field so it
certainly is not anything that will be
an immediate solution per se for
Russia's shortcomings on the battlefield
here in Ukraine but certainly it's
something that the Ukrainian military is
watching closely because they now know
that assuming Russia goes forward with
this there is many as 300 000 reservists
boots on the ground if you will that
Russia will have at their disposal
moving forward in this war
and obviously the Ukrainian forces are
going to be facing off against 300 000
reserves as they move up just talk us
through where Ukraine stands in terms of
the conflict what personnel and what
material it's putting forward and
putting onto the front lines
well the initial reaction from the
ukrainians is they are not too concerned
about this I mean it's clear certainly a
lot of more soldiers that Russia is
putting into the fight but the
ukrainians feel that they have two
things very much in their advantage that
they had since the beginning of the war
and they've only grown more so in the
last seven months since this war has
been going on and that's number one
motivation they feel that the Ukraine
the ukrainians feel that they're very
highly motivated defending what they
feel is very much their land against
what they feel is very much an illegal
full-scale Invasion by Russia and they
also now in the last few months have
been getting more and more sophisticated
weapons from the west from the UK from
Germany from France from Poland but also
primarily from the United States it has
given more than 15 billion dollars
billion with a B in military aid to the
ukrainians in sophisticated weapons that
they've been using quite effectively to
not only stop the Russian advance
but actually push the Russians back and
retake territory as we saw in the
Northeast defensive where the ukrainians
in a matter of almost a few days retook
almost all of the Northeast region of
harakiva so the ukrainians feel they are
in a very good position and they feel
that they don't feel too much concern
with hundreds of thousands of Russian
reservists now potentially in the
battlefield they feel that uh they feel
that what they've shown so far is that
they can contain the Russians and that
the the war from their standpoint will
not change Gabriel thank you very much
Gabriel Alexander talking to this from
Kiev
she tells us more about what the Russian
military mobilization means for
Ukrainian troops on the ground
aren't you where there are multiple
front lines here in the northeast of the
country
um you know the ukrainians have been
since the beginning of the month uh
going ahead with this counter offensive
that has taken really Everyone by
surprise and I'm supposing also the
Russians considering how quickly they
retreated and they abandoned uh these
the kharkiv region now ukrainians have
been saying that they were the the
Russian soldiers here who also had among
them some of the separatist forces from
the lugan's region were understaffed and
under
um and under equipped in this part of
the country as the Russians had moved a
lot of their capabilities to other areas
like the donbass region like Herson
region in the south of the country where
also another Ukrainian counter-offensive
is expected so there is need for the
Russians to have more or Personnel here
there is needed for them to have more
military hardware here Samuel Roman is
an associate fellow with the Royal
United Services Institute he explains
why President Putin's ordered a partial
mobilization
if you look at Russian estimates for
example Russian Senator vladimirov just
made a statement and said that in some
areas of the occupied regions Ukraine
has got a three to one Manpower
Advantage generally for successful
counter-offensive for a military
standpoint you need to have between two
or three times as many forces on the
Ukrainian side than on the Russian side
and the Russians are hoping that even if
this is not doctor in the tide of the
war and lead to Market Russian
territorial expansions it will help to
avoid defeats like the withdrawal that
we saw from Clark Heath a few weeks back
initial assessment from the Russian
military and also from Russian lawmakers
that General mobilization is not
necessary a general mobilization would
also be much more controversial
politically for example Sergey showing
you the Russian defense made it very
clear that students and conscripts under
the age of 27 are not going to be uh
brought into this war this is just going
to be a mobilization for reservists and
that's a very strategic decision because
the popularity of this war amongst those
between 18 and 30 is significantly less
that is amongst those who are in their
40s or 50s